this is a Tory crisis created in Downing
Street but being paid for by ordinary
working people and so much damage has
already been done with families paying
higher mortgage rates and worrying about
their pensions it's not just time for
another conservative Chancellor it's
time for a labor government because only
labor have the plans to grow our economy
and provide the economic stability that
our country desperately needs with a
recognition that wealth does not just
come from the top down but it's created
by ordinary working people right across
our country
the list is saying that the decisions
that she's been making today are going
to help towards the stability that you
say that the country needs you don't
believe that so much damage has already
been done and people are having
sleepless nights because of the higher
mortgage rates they're now paying and
the worrying as well about what's
happening to their pensions the partial
U-turn today does not reverse the whole
budget which is what is needed the
government need to go back to the
drawing board not just picking out
individual measures we need a budget
that adds up with an independent
forecast from the office for Budget
responsibility but the truth is the
trickle-down tired economics of the
conservatives no longer works and it is
time for a labor government that
prioritizes ordinary working people not
this belief that somehow the tax cuts to
the richest will somehow filter down to
everybody else this dress has taken
action she's got rid of her Chancellor
the second shortest tenure of a
Chancellor in history is that going to
make any difference well now on the
fourth conservative Chancellor this year
in fact we're on the fourth conservative
Chancellor since July this year the
truth is another change in who is
running the treasury another Tory
Chancellor isn't the answer to the
challenges that we face as a country the
toys are out of ideas they're out of
time it's time for a labor government so
of course local general election but
that's not going to
have services are at the moment would
even consider uh calling the general
election so it's just not going to
happen because it's not reality well
it's time for the prime minister to
actually put the country first and at
the very least she should go back to the
drawing board with her budget that was
devised in lockstep with the former
Chancellor of the exchequer produced an
independent forecast alongside that
budget and get rid of the whole range of
unfunded tax cards that were introduced
just three weeks ago that has caused
this instability in financial markets
with real costs for ordinary working
people with higher mortgage rates and
fears about pensions so if Rachel
Williams has made Chancellor today
rather than Jeremy Hunt what would you
do differently what would you do to put
this right
well first of all we need to respect
Economic Institutions the undermining of
the bank of England the sacking of the
permanent Secretary of the Treasury the
gagging of the officer budget
responsibility have all added to the
volatility in financial markets along
with the scale of the unfunded tax cuts
that labor would always put fiscal
responsibility and economic credibility
first because we know that is so
important for family finances and
Labor's plans for growth investing in
the industries of the future with our
green Prosperity plan reform of business
rates to help our high streets and small
businesses making Britain the best place
to start and grow a business that's at
the heart of Labor's plans for economic
growth and stability a world apart from
the trickle-down economics that we see
from Liz truss and her conservative
government less stress quite saying did
push forward with the same policy she's
now saying it's more his responsibility
than hers but she's now brought in
Jeremy like someone who sided with which
is
foreign
beginning to show signs of being
prepared to listen to to other voices
well Jeremy Hunt when he ran to be
leader of the conservative party
proposed even bigger cuts to corporation
tax than what the Prime Minister and
causing uh brought in so the idea that
somehow this is a break with the failed
trickle-down economics that we've seen
from the conservatives in uh recent
weeks it's just for the birds Jeremy
Hunt like cozy carting and Liz truss
signs up to this trickle-down model of
Economics which has failed our country
and has resulted in the instability and
the insecurity and volatility that we've
seen in the last three weeks since the
former Chancellor's mini budget of
course conservatives are at a very low
point of those very weak points at the
moment but in all honesty would labor
want to take power at the moment there
are so many external factors there are
so many factors which are causing the
economic turmoil will they ever really
want to take charge of such an unstable
shift the truth is that the UK is the
only country in the world where our
central banks have to intervene three
times in less than three weeks to
protect UK Financial stability a change
of government and a labor government is
exactly what is needed to provide the
economic stability that investors and
families need and we're ready to provide
that leadership
so reaction coming in from across the
political Spectrum here in Westminster
we're going to hear from suret Davey
leader of the lib Dems in a moment but
that was shot a Chancellor Rachel Reeves
saying the government needs to go back
to the drawing board it's not just time
for another conservative Chancellor it's
time for labor government our Deputy
political editor some coats are still
here in Downing Street and Sam you
picked up on something Rachel Reeve said
there about the possibility of a general
election labor doing so well in the
polls they'd love a general election but
what's their thinking on it at the
moment no surprise that an opposition
party wants to get some political credit
and make some physical capital what is
interesting what we're listening for is
the tactics of how to get a general
election now if labor believes that
there are 40 plus Tory MPS willing to
vote down this government and trigger a
general election then they'll call that
vote but in that little broadcast pool
clip the interview on behalf of all the
broadcasters Rachel Reeves was asked
should there be a general election now
will you do anything about that she said
well she basically gave a null answer
and started talking about going back to
the drawing board I think it's a very
clear signal that as of today despite
everything labor don't think there are
the numbers of Tory MPS yet willing to
vote with them on a vote in their
confidence to trigger an election
so we so we go on